Many machine knitters
complain about their stash.
"I have so much yarn,
I'll never use it in this lifetime."
Well, put it to use.
There are people out there who could
use knitted items that you can make.
Dust off that machine, use up that yarn,
and get a feeling of satisfaction
for making something
for someone who's in need.
Plan on learning techniques and practicing
the skills that you need
to improve your knitting.
Here are six ways that you can
knit for charity and help others.
Knitting blankets or lap robes is
a wonderful way to provide warmth
and comfort to those in need.
Think about preemies and newborns,
the elderly, those undergoing chemo,
or homeless shelters.
Animal shelters also provide
blankets for our furry friends.
Consider washable,
soft yarns for blankets.
But the sky's the limit in using
color and stitch patterns.
A really easy blanket is
our Right Angles Blanket.
This is a great exercise
in learning about gauge.
Knit a swatch
and let our pattern determine the stitches
and rows for your blanket size.
We even include a tool to help you
determine if you have enough
yarn for the size you've chosen.
Knit four to six squares,
attach them together (as
you knit) for minimal finishing.
Susanna's Blanket adds the challenge
of short row shaping
for its interesting design.
It's a fun one to knit,
especially in self-striping yarns.
Knitted hats are always in demand,
especially during the colder months.
You can donate them to homeless shelters,
hospitals, or organizations
that support cancer patients.
Or you can knit for premature babies.
Experiment with different patterns
and yarns to create a variety of styles.
Hats can just be plain old rectangles,
easy to knit.
With our Mile-a-Minute Hat project,
you cast on one time and you can knit a
handful of hats in one knitting session.
Once they're off the machine,
seam up and finish the hat in front
of the TV or out on the deck.
Maybe you'll challenge yourself to shape
the top of a hat for great fit.
Dust off your ribber and knit
some hats in the round.
Any hat with a fold up brim will fit
almost anyone, and the doubled
brim makes for warmer ears.
If you are in the US,
let me remind you of Linda Williams' hat
contest at Country Knitting of Maine.
Another quick and easy and useful
project are soap sacks.
These are washcloth pouches that can be
practical to donate and a thoughtful gift.
They hold bars of soap and double
as exfoliating washcloths.
Donate them to homeless shelters or
organizations that offer
hygiene items to those in need.
Stacey at soapsacks.
Com inspired me to put all those bits
and pieces of cotton yarn to good use.
Plus I've had so much fun knitting
a simple 4 inch by 6 inch project,
knowing that I'm helping someone in need.
How about some more rectangles?
Scarfs and shawls can
provide warmth and comfort.
Consider knitting various lengths,
colors, and stitch patterns.
Donate them to homeless shelters,
women's shelters, or organizations
that support people facing cold weather.
I've discovered that when
my neck is warm, I'm warm.
Maybe a needy person's coat
or jacket isn't very warm.
A scarf can add extra comfort in cold
weather, and you can help them stay warm.
If you've graduated past a plain old
rectangle, consider our butterfly shawl.
The shaping is easy and it adds a bit
of interest to the knitting
and to the finished shawl.
Here's another reason to dust off
that ribber or garter carriage.
Play with stitch patterns and sizes and
use our Rectangle Square tool to calculate
how many stitches to cast
on and how many rows to knit.
Use our Yarn Calculator to determine if
you have enough yarn to
knit the size you've chosen.
Are you ready for a challenge?
How about mittens?
Handknitted mittens are
welcome during the winter.
Choose soft and insulating
yarns to keep hands cozy.
Look for organizations that collect winter
accessories for children or the homeless.
Our mitten collection has five
styles and eight customizable sizes.
You can create easy to knit,
comfortable mittens.
Are you feeling extra ambitious?
Maybe you're looking to learn or
practice some new-to-you techniques.
Use up that yarn with our easiest
and fastest sweater pattern the
Kid's Squirrel Cardigan.
If you can cast on and bind off,
then you can knit this.
It's knit in one piece
with just two side seams.
Another one-piece quickie is our
two hour child and infant cardigan.
This one gives you good short row
practice and can be finished in no time.
Don't be afraid to knit sweaters.
Will they be perfect?
Probably not.
Will they be judged at the county fair?
No.
The recipient will be happy to have
something warm to slip
on that was made with love.
I encourage you to use up that yarn,
put your machine to use,
and knit for charity.
You'll feel great helping others.
Happy knitting.